hey twig you want to help us get outta
here s got money get a gift in 17 days
the thing I wore my hand we told you it
was this big
that's my newest conquer let's just
agree to never discuss this
hey youtubers is Charlie all kinds of
Marvel bombs being dropped for all the
movies but the biggest thing is Adam
warlock we got so much information about
his character in the MCU so really good
news if you're a big fan of the Adam
warlock character he is coming to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe confirmed
there was a bunch of people talking
about it at the junket for guardians of
the galaxy - so there's a couple hoops
to jump through it's a little
complicated but if you're new to the
channel I do Marvel videos every week be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there's even a spider-man giveaway going
on that I'll explain at the end of the
video but what happened is is that James
Gunn was doing a bunch of q and A's for
the film a couple months ago like hey
the first trailers out what do you guys
think this is so amazing there were a
couple things he revealed were cut out
during the treatment stage when he was
writing the screenplay in one of those
things was a really big character that
he wanted to include but there were just
too many people and he didn't want to
sacrifice the Mantis character because
she was a little more important to the
story of guardians of the galaxy - in
this other really favorite character of
his so now it's come out during the
junket that that favorite character was
Adam warlock himself so for everybody
who was complaining where's Adam warlock
he's so important for the soul gem for
the Thanos storyline in Infinity
Gauntlet now we have the answer so they
always changed things from the comics to
the MCU movies but Kevin Feige in a
separate interview just confirmed that
he would be part of guardians 3 now they
could always change their mind about
that but they did say that he'd be an
important part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
eventually guardians 3 would be the
jumping off point for that so that kind
of low-key confirms that Adam warlock
isn't going to be an infinity war or the
fourth Avengers film which i think is
fine like is they're not going to do the
soul gem Adam warlock storyline which
I'll explain in a second then they might
as well do something completely
different but they also confirmed that
the third guardians film which will be
phase 4 will be the last story with the
current roster now that doesn't mean
that every single character in the
guardians movies won't come back for
like a fourth Guardians film or they
won't make a fourth Guardians film but
it'll probably look more like what's
going on with Iron Man in the other
Marvel films like there hasn't been a
fourth Iron Man film but there have been
a lot of movies with Iron Man in it so
you'll probably see the guardians
characters pop up and other
people's cosmic movies but when
everybody saw that a Yesha was going to
be a really big character and in the
comics her name is kismet she's created
by the same group of people that create
Adam warlock they're all created using
these cocoons the one that we saw in the
collectors workshop which James Gunn
confirmed is actually not Adam warlocks
cocoon so a lot of people were
disappointed about that but when a Yesha
showed up it's like oh my god
even though they're calling them the
sovereign and it's a slightly different
group of people there was a lot of
confusion because it's like oh my god
does this mean they're laying seeds for
Adam warlock his people are debuting in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe does that
mean that he's somewhere in the
background so because James Gunn is such
a big comic book nerd and even though
minor things get changed he's relatively
true to people's origins in the comics
when we do see out a warlock we will see
a version of the cocoon in the storyline
will probably be something closer to his
annihilation conquest storyline which is
really interesting because that's the
storyline of the modern guardians team
this one right here coming together in
the comics but most of you know about
the big changes they already made to
that storyline Ultron was the big
villain the phalanx star-lord the other
Guardians went to Adam warlock to get
help with that so Adam warlock was the
big part of that Guardians team but
Cosmo is also there James Gunn also said
that Cosmo the big problem with that is
that it just looks weird next to a CG
rocket on screen so it's more of a
technical problem than a character
problem when it comes to Cosmo but Adam
warlock had already been through the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline infinity
watch in a whole bunch of jim Starlin
classic 7d stories even through the 90s
before he ever participated in this
annihilation conquest storyline so
there's a lot of deep Adam warlock cuts
that they could pull from whenever they
bring him on screen just don't expect it
to be exactly like the comics because so
much of that is tied up with Panos the
infinity gems in the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline which is largely being mine
for the infinity war movies so there's
going to be a whole bunch of changes but
don't worry obviously I'll do videos for
that stuff when we start to get more
information if you've never read an Adam
warlock story so he debuted way way back
in the 60s in a Fantastic Four comic he
was created by this group called The
Enclave they do a lot of genetic
engineering
they want to create these perfect people
that to the sovereign are in the
guardians of the galaxy movie this race
of genetically perfect people they all
look gold the Enclave in the comics is
really just a group of scientists on
earth that created Adam warlock but he
came out of that cocoon looking all gold
he was meant to be this christ-like
figure who then went on to gain
possession of the soul gem and use it to
save this planet called counter-earth
from a big attack then he learns about
the universal Church of truth led by
this corrupt figure called the mages in
the big shocking reveal we learned is
that the mages is a corrupted future
version of Adam warlock who's been
corrupted by the power of the soul gem
come back in time to just be this
conquering figure so Adam warlock
himself changes his own timeline so it
becomes this time travel story and then
during the Marvel team-up comics he runs
afoul of Thanos and learns about the
other five gems so you start to get an
inkling of the idea of the Infinity
Gauntlet so Santos gains possession of
the gems this is all before the Infinity
Gauntlet and wants to use them to
destroy earth Sun there's a team-up they
defeat him and eventually Adam warlock
gets transmuted into the soul gem itself
which has this place called the soul
world which is a pocket dimension that
houses all the souls that the soul gem
takes that's its power it has the power
to control souls so when people say that
Adam warlock is trapped inside the soul
gem it's just like a small pocket
universe he later comes back out after
the Silver Surfer goes around trying to
tell people that Thanos is trying to
assemble the Infinity Gauntlet so this
is all during fan oohs quest like oh my
god
Thanos has this crazy idea to alter the
universe by combining all the infinity
gems so he goes into the soul gem to get
Adam warlocks help you have the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline Adam warlock gains
possession of the gauntlet by the end of
that The Living Tribunal gives him this
order that he has to separate all the
gems because they're too dangerous
together then Adam warlock goes on to
create the Infinity watch and then if
you've heard of the infinity war comic
book that's very different from the
infinity war movie so the infinity war
movie is based on the Infinity Gauntlet
my book storyline the infinity war comic
book storyline came after the Infinity
Gauntlet and that gets really trippy
it's kind of confusing but Adam warlock
has two different selves to get
separated from him one is the mages
remember I talked about him and the
other is the goddess so there's these
two aspects of Adam warlock and serve as
the antagonist for the infinity war
storyline in the comics they're probably
not going to do that in the movies so
you don't need to worry about it if you
haven't read it it was just meant to be
a sequel to the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline if you've heard about the
cancerverse in the more recent Adam
warlock stories I mean it's still a
while ago but it's kind of an old story
that took place after annihilation
conquest where the mages comes back the
universal Church of truth is the
cancerverse become a big thing so right
now the stand-in for the cancerverse
if they ever do a story like that with
the Marvel Universe is sort of dr.
Strange's Dark Dimension which is ruled
over by Dormammu so they ever want to do
cancerverse
they'll probably substitute Dormammu in
the Dark Dimension for that whatever
they do with guardians 3 in Adam warlock
it'll probably serve as a jumping-off
point for that character if they want to
continue to use them in the Marvel
Universe and they're a couple of big
characters that they do introduce and
guardians to like ego the Living Planet
that will continue to be big people in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe not just
the guardians films but some of the
characters that they introduce some of
the post-credits scenes are kind of
spoilery so I will do a separate post
credit scene video when we get closer to
the movie coming out but most people
haven't seen the movie so try not to
post spoilers in the comments below
because some of you might get to see it
before other people but the other cool
thing that James Gunn revealed is that
the third guardians film would serve as
the end of a singular story that would
comprise all three Guardians films but
make sure you stay through the entire
end credit because there are a couple
big things that happen the directly hat
tip what they're going to be following
up on so they're like a couple clear
jumping-off plot points that they set up
for the third guardians film but we can
talk about that when we get closer to
the movie because it does get kind of
spoilery so what's going to happen next
is is they dropped a whole bunch of
marble bombs there's new thor ragnarok
there's new black panther so I'll try to
get those videos out as fast as possible
there's also some real
cool Rick and Morty stuff but like I
said there's a new round of the
spider-man giveaway all you have to do
to enter that is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video while you wait for
more Marvel you can click here to learn
all about Captain Marvel and spider-man
in that fourth Avengers film and you can
click here for a brand new game of
Thrones promo breakdown thank you so
much for watching let's high five I'll
see you guys in the next video
you